oh no my blurriness wait
why am i blurry so i lost focus there
for a moment
okay i'm still alive let's play one more
game
if i'm black i'm gonna go for for dutch
or maybe stafford or maybe we'll just
meditate for the next
however long it takes for me to get a
game
oh i discovered a new line in the
stafford
which i haven't gotten yet on stream
actually i discovered a few new lines
should i take a moment and share
i could share some prep because this is
kind of taking a while i'll share
just one kind of cool variation actually
discovered today
i'll go back to the study okay let me
see if i can remember this
so stafford gambit one of the trickiest
things with playing stafford
at a higher level is all the different
kind of move order
transpositions and keeping track like
which move to play against which lines
there's specific
variations which require very precise
play
so the line i want to show
white can play in d3 i guess knight c3
there's some transpositions but let's
say d3
this is all very standard there's a trap
if uh at bishop g5 this is
oh no my queen trap which
i still get tweets from time to time
people getting this in their own games
um of course if knight c3 there's knight
g4 and this is
also good for black so the line i want
to show
is when white plays bishop e2
we go for h5 and then
white can either castle here or play
knight c3 but there's going to be some
transposition let's say
knight c3 castling or um knight c3 you
play knight g4
wholesome thoughts on the benko gambit
and deja vu i was a while ago
i played the game in the bank oh earlier
this stream
a binko yeah it's an interesting opening
it's it's one that i haven't studied so
much as black
have you ever played the up dog gambit
what's up dog
alexa what's up dog
i'm feeling super because the american
astronomical
society just launched the super bowl of
astronomy
it's going to be a star-studded event
oh like what's up in this
upwards like direction opposite of down
okay anyway going back to this line
um so it's a case where white allows
knight g4
castles you might not get this too often
because white's casting into
an attack and i think a lot of people
like if we look at the stats
yeah queen h4 is probably the choice for
a lot of people
uh which scores really well ah
because so many people play h3
and then yeah then white loses f2 so
queen h4 is not the best move
because white can take and even though
you got h file bishop f4
kind of kills black's attack
so the best move
also to show queen d6
it's still fun looking like there's a
lot of games where black will win
quickly by meeting
um but objectively this isn't the best
because bishop g4
[Music]
pawn takes and then e5 is really strong
if you take there's rookie one
so if you get to this position i mean
you can still kind of get by with these
moves and maybe have some success
but the best move and the computer
approved
recommendation is queen
f6
and the idea is you're still attacking
f2 so you still keep initiative
and you're also preventing bishop f4
which will be relevant at some point
um so
the line i discovered today it's really
cool because very natural move most
played move is bishop f3
then the move to play here is queen e5
which is almost a novelty
i see full den had this position once
a queen e5 so you're um
now you're tagging along this diagonal
and you don't have to worry about the
pawn getting in the way
and the potential ping so
most natural move for light is g3
and then there's a really cool sequence
knight takes h2 bam and this is
it's kind of an intuitive sacrifice king
takes h2
h4 it's like it's really really nice
because you you have so much alignment
against the king
i just realized did we get through all
the sub
notifications it feels so quiet now
thanks again yeah thanks to all like so
much support
um let me let me show i'm trying to
provide as much value as possible
so let me show what can happen here
because white's already
in in some danger of course we're
threatening to take and just
rampage the king side
so it looks natural for white to just
move the king
away from the alignment
now i'm going to give this as a puzzle
let's make this the main line
black to move
find the only winning move
if doesn't if [ __ ] doesn't play the
right move then black is losing
keep in mind you're down a piece
so you have to play very precisely to
finish off attack okay let's see what
people are saying so bishop f2
queen takes g3 bishop h3
pawn h3
okay so i'm going to make a poll and
we'll see we'll see how
strong uh twitch chat will be
a poll is still going bishop h3 is
leading 50 percent
yeah queen takes g3 would be good
if the pawn couldn't just take back
unfortunately that doesn't quite work
h3 yeah so i'm gonna go through like the
moves that don't work
so queen g3 no good h3 also no good
kazan king h2 and black's attack kind of
just dies
because the rook is brook and bishop are
blocked by the pawn
okay so good job bishop h3 won the poll
bishop h3
is uh the winning move you sacrifice
another piece
but for good reason because after takes
takes
the king is not coming out alive
and the eventual maid is actually quite
nice
whoa it's swift trout 720 that's a new
name
thanks for gifting five subs so let me
show the mate
king g2 rook h2 king here
good job to anyone who thought this far
ahead
after pawn takes queen still defends the
rook
takes now it's made in two
queen g3 bishop g2 and very sly
queen g2 and the rook is pinned
so anyway that's kind of the new
variation i
i discovered today um
it's kind of like a natural looking line
it's a variation like i guess i haven't
looked at so closely before because a
lot of people
don't willingly go into this sort of
attack but
um i discovered this partly with the
engine like engine will recommend queen
f6
objectively the the best way
to play
so yet another reason to go for stafford
but what if the king doesn't take on h3
if the king doesn't take i guess first
of all if king ji won
you can take advantage of this pin and
take
this way oh there's a really cool light
oh wow look at this um
i'm going to turn off the engine there's
a really cool move coming up
so you take here well it has to move
into the corner
because it's illegal for the pawn to
take
look at this move coming up bishop takes
f1
now this is like just an engine move
maybe it would be findable with enough
time
you lose your queen now the pawn is no
longer pinned
but then you take back with discovered
soon to be discovered check
it's not quite mate because white has
this move and the bishop's defended
but then you make another queen go away
windows
you make another queen with g2
king h2 and then you can make a bishop
too
bishop this is not the responsible thing
to do
this is probably losing now for black
yeah don't make a bishop make a queen
it's made in one
that's really cool so you suck a queen
and then you just
instant uh instantly make a new queen
yeah so many hidden gems i should make
this a main line
thanks to whoever was asking that
question what if the king doesn't
take on h3 i guess the other line maybe
it's more natural
the problem for white if the king moves
this way we're going to take the rook
and then unleash the the beast on h8
so everything kind of fails for white
but it's good to always like i guess be
aware of the branches
and white is losing in every single
branch
so um yeah that's kind of a mini staffer
gambit lesson
a new line that i discovered earlier
if i get around to it maybe i'll put
this on youtube
because a lot of my staffer content it's
like games that i play
where i'm tricking people in like known
traps
but this is kind of a brand new line
more uh
it's more lesson content too something i
want to do more of for youtube
so if you're watching on youtube you can
watch on twitch
in real time and say hi in the twitch
chat
oh and if you have amazon prime you can
subscribe for free